I mentioned on the last show of 2017
which feels like it was a long time ago
now actually yeah that we would not be
selling david pakman show 2018 calendars
deep into 2018 and we're very close to
totally wrapped up we have seven
calendars left we have at this point
it's just what's left from the orders
that we've made of calendars I have
seven calendars left okay if you want
one of these last seven calendars and
the calendar is made of 100% original
art from three different David Pakman
show viewers an original cover from Dan
Burke as well as some comic strips by
Dan Burke and other images including a
hybrid image that was put together in
concert between Cory Top kiss and
Anthony Petra mall and I know that Cory
was not thrilled with this
bastardization of his Andy Warhol esque
image oh yeah but for a number of
different logistical reasons it had to
happen this way with Anthony Petra mall
has helped so I think it actually all
came together really nice artists are
very particular about that stuff oh yeah
you don't you don't want to bother an
artist with changes to their work and
and so we took some liberties in putting
this thing together anyway we have seven
of these calendars left two ways to get
them and they're both at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 okay if you
want to get the calendar for free and
autographed with a new David Pakman show
yearly membership you can do it at david
pakman.com slash calendar 18 if you want
just the calendar and it can be
autographed or not you also do it at
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 how
will you know if we still have any of
these seven calendars remaining if you
go to david pakman.com slash calendar 18
and you are allowed to order a calendar
then that means we still have some of
those seven remaining if you go to that
page and it says 2018 calendar sales
have ended then you will know that's it
and there are no more calendars until
next year if we do this which at this
point I think we should it's been four
or five years in a row it's kind of
becoming a tradition it's a tradition
how you're gonna end that I guess just I
never fight by not mentioning it and
hoping nobody notices but that didn't
work in 2017 people demanded a 20
eighteen calendar okay so check that out
david pakman.com slash calendar 18 7
calendars left